[MUSIC PLAYING]
LORIN PRICE: Today we are here
with Taylor from Quantiphi,
who is the practice lead
for Public Sector and Higher
Education.
We're very excited to explore
some of the solutions built
by Quantiphi.
Before we begin,
Taylor, can you tell us
a little bit about Quantiphi?
TAYLOR CYR: Yes, of course.
We've been around six years now.
And we focus primarily on AI
and machine learning solutions.
We found that we're able
to provide a lot of value
for customers by helping
them with their data strategy
as well because that's one
of the fundamental building
blocks of any AI
or ML initiative.
We have been a Google
Cloud Partner since 2016.
Obviously, with that AI
machine learning background,
we've been very close
with Google Cloud.
We have 325 GCP
certified professionals,
which is about a quarter
of our workforce.
We've actually been the 2017
and 2018 Machine Learning
Partner of the Year, and are
a Contact Center AI launch
partner as well.
LORIN PRICE: That's awesome.
Congrats on the ML
Partner of the Year
and for being a
CCAI launch partner.
Can you tell us a
bit more about CCAI
and what it means to
be a launch partner?
TAYLOR CYR: Yeah.
So there's three
components to CCAI.
There's a topic
modeler, which uses
keyword clustering to identify
high-frequency topics.
There's Dialogflow,
which is the NLP
backend, kind of the
virtual agent, so to speak.
And then if there
is an instance where
it needs to be transferred
to a live agent,
there's functionality
called Agent Assist
that uses a real-time keyword
search from the conversation
between the live
agent and the customer
to pull up suggestions
from the knowledge base
and help them answer
questions quickly.
As a launch partner,
we help customers
through the entire
lifecycle of the deployment.
So that's everything
from helping
them design conversation
flows, programming intents,
building integrations
with the knowledge base
CRM systems, anywhere else
that user data might exist.
And then, also, building
that Agent Assist
functionality as well.
LORIN PRICE: Great.
Thanks for sharing
more about that.
Can you talk more in depth
about the types of technologies
that Quantiphi uses?
TAYLOR CYR: Yeah.
So because we've
been using Dialogflow
since before it was even
actually called Dialogflow,
we've built a lot of custom
machine learning models
that help you build, manage, and
deploy any of these Dialogflow
or Contact Center AI solutions.
One of them is intent
identification.
So that takes your
historical call or chat logs,
understands the
ways that users are
asking questions, and
programs that context directly
into the virtual agent.
Another involves the
ingestion of text.
So think a knowledge base, or
a FAQ section on your web page.
It pulls out questions and
answer pairs there, and again
makes it directly programmable
into the virtual agent.
We also work a lot with
the NLP sentiment analysis
that exists in
Dialogflow, taking it
a step further in what
we call emotion analysis.
So trying to
understand when users
are having these
negative feelings,
identifying that earlier, and
helping you intervene before it
starts becoming too
negative of an impact
on customer satisfaction.
Lastly, we deal a lot
with integrations.
So having your users or
constituents reach out to you
on whatever platform they
feel comfortable is very
important to creating
value for the people that
will be interacting
with the solution,
whether that be voice, chat,
messenger platforms, SMS,
Dialogflow has all those
integrations built in
and very easily accessible.
LORIN PRICE: Can you talk about
some of the specific solutions
that Quantiphi has
built with CCAI?
TAYLOR CYR: Yeah.
So when a lot of people
hear Contact Center AI,
they think of the
traditional call center.
While it's a great
tool for that,
we found that the NLP
capabilities behind Dialogflow
are actually useful in a lot
of other situations as well.
There was some work that
we did in conjunction
with Google Cloud and
Penn State World Campus
where we used the NLP
capabilities of Dialogflow.
It identified four
different types
of student requests, where
advisors were spending up
to 5,000 hours per year
really just pulling
different pieces of
information, determining
a student's eligibility
to change major, campus,
something like that.
So we use Dialogflow
to recognize
the intents of those users,
provide a template in response
to the advisor, that can
then be personalized based
on the student, all while
pulling all of that data
that they had to
spend 15 minutes
gathering, putting it
right in front of them,
and giving them the opportunity
to add value with their time,
rather than just
searching for data.
LORIN PRICE: What are
some of the challenges
that you've encountered when
building these solutions?
TAYLOR CYR: Yeah.
So the first one
that comes to mind
is designing conversation flows.
Not always do
customers understand
what they want to
automate and how they want
the agent to say it.
So we found that, with
using the topic modeler,
you cannot only find a lot
of the high-frequency topics,
but you can dig down a level,
understand within those topics
what people are talking
about, and help structure
the conversation flow of the
virtual agent using that.
We've also seen
intent clashing a lot.
So as you continue to
add intents to the bot,
it becomes more and
more likely that there's
going to be similarities
between an existing intent.
So we've created an
automated solution testing
tool that goes through and tests
those intents every so often,
and gives you an early
indication if there's
going to be problems
with a previous intent
so that you can intervene
and fix that before it ever
sees the light of day.
LORIN PRICE: Well, this
has been very interesting.
Thank you so much for
being here with us today.
TAYLOR CYR: It was my pleasure.
LORIN PRICE: If you'd like to
learn more about Quantiphi,
you can visit quantiphi.com.
Thanks for watching, and
stay tuned for more episodes
of "Stack Chat."
[MUSIC PLAYING]